imagine how a woman feels imagine how
soft and warm our skin feels imagine the
sweet smell of her perfume
imagine her tenderly pressing as soft
lips against yours
imagine her letting you get on top of
him and insert you inside her softly
moaning as it slides in imagine the
walls of her tight
soft warm wrapped around every inch of
you imagine her breathing getting
heavier with every thrust imagine her
wrapping her arms and legs around you
holding you as close as she possibly can
and begging you to inside her as you
release every ounce of yours into her
and imagine the feeling of pure
satisfaction and peace that comes
afterwards and looking beside you to see
a person that cares about you and has
accepted you in the most intimate way
possible you will never get to
experience this because your skeleton is
too small or the bones in your face and
not the proper shape have a nice day
[Music]
hello boys let's talk about bone
structure
[Music]
there's something basically Soviet about
the way the internet names things Stalin
had portmanteaus like agitprop Politburo
and compromise and we have webinar
podcast and insel short for involuntary
celibate the word insult was invented in
the late 90s by a lonely bisexual called
Ilana who created a website called
Alana's and voluntary celibacy project
it was essentially a safe space for
people who just couldn't get it in but
in our own miserable moment of internet
history the word in cell refers to a
more specific community of mostly
heterosexual men centered around forums
like in assault me and our slash brain
cells
this group has recently gotten a lot of
bad press because for the last few years
they've been churning out mass murderers
faster than Marvel can make Avengers
movies but most in cells aren't violent
killers they're just men who formed an
identity around not getting laid in this
video I don't want to mock in cells or
lecture them or even sympathize with
them I just want to understand who they
are and why they're like this to start
with sometimes the best way to
understand a person's world is to learn
their language and the language of the
in cells about you'll see first base in
sillies does it ever bother you that the
word women makes adult females sound
just a little bit too human well in
cells have a solution to that we've
taken to calling women
[Applause]
the choice of vocabulary tells us how
insults think of women not as sisters or
mothers and certainly not as autonomous
people but as a kind of foreign
inscrutable object comparable to a
natural resource unobtainium to which n
cells believe all men are entitled into
which they feel they have been unjustly
denied there's a long tradition of nerdy
men talking about women in nerdily
misogynistic ways a reminded of famed
rocket scientist fair enough on brown's
remark about female astronauts we are
reserving
than ten pounds of payload for
recreational equipment which is not to
say that alpha males are less
misogynistic than nerds but simply that
nerds have a nerdy style of misogyny now
fee mode is about as neutral a term as
in cells half for women and it's only
downhill from there there's the usual
standbys [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] while
conveying a searing resentment of female
sexuality the pinnacle of which is
represented by the bespoke insel coinage
roasty which i'm sorry to inform you
refers to the insult believe that the
human vulva become mutilated through
repeated penetration by different men
though not through repeated penetration
by the same man interestingly and
thereby come to resemble roast beef now
by definition in cells haven't actually
observed any vaginas but to n cells
Anatomy is more a matter of metaphysical
speculation than crude science though if
you ask me the right metaphor for a
veteran vag is not roast beef but sour
greens of course not all females are
created equal
there are various subspecies the Becca
hue or nor me free mode is to be
contrasted with the Stacey or sexually
desirable female whose distinguishing
features include make up on point never
works a day in her life naturally curvy
body gives men instant erections big
tits and ass show fertility leave my
buns alone you savages the Stasi
naturally has a male counterpart whom in
cells called the Chad a Chad is a hunky
alpha whose hands are always prepared to
grab nearby fertile [ __ ] he has never
heard a song in his entire life he has a
sloped forehead with a strong brow
rambhau chin strong jawline flat
occipital plate it must needs be
remarked but the skull of the Chad
exhibited the brow Ridge most pronounced
whereas the skull of the Virgin is most
inadequate in this regard predisposing
such specimens to an abject existence of
lamentation and cuckold rare it's time
to talk about bone structure according
to a classic in Soul mean the difference
between Chad and long Chad is literally
a few millimeters of bone I would like
to propose a sociological theory fentons
law once bigotry or self-loathing
permeate a given community it is only a
matter of time before deep metaphysical
significance is assigned to the shape of
human skulls
why skulls you ask well the best
explanation I can come up with is that a
skull is inanimate and unchangeable it's
there for the perfect symbol of the
intrinsic and permanent characteristics
that bigots like to assign to certain
groups of people if you believe for
example that a certain race or gender is
intellectually inferior you can justify
your belief by pointing to the shape of
the skull and saying well that's the
reason why it's just nature there's
nothing that can be done about it
and that is exactly the way in cells
think about love and celibacy mankind is
divided into two groups of people
the Chad's with the [ __ ] skulls and
the in cells whose bones come up a few
millimeters short korndog anyone I'm
really hungry of course there's not just
the skulls the insoles blame for their
sexlessness they have a whole dictionary
of jharkhand explaining the causes of
involuntary celibacy height cells are
insulted their inferior stature
whereas mental cells can attract women
because of mental illness or autism or
they're addicts and then called drug
cells risk cells on the other hand are
doomed by their overly delicate wrists
no obsessing about your wrist size does
seem a little weird oh yeah is it a
little weird that the average dildo has
more girth than my wrist is it weird at
all but some men have thicker dicks than
my wrists but yeah obviously obsessing
about my tiny wrists that are smaller
than even many women's is completely a
rational body dysmorphia and the reason
why no one wants to be with me or even
talked to me is my shitty personality
even though literal 80 IQ men who have
nothing to talk about except who won the
last night are still able to attract a
loving partner interesting a significant
number of in cells are not white in
which case their unfuck ability is
attributed to race and they are
accordingly termed apologies in advance
black cells race cells kuri cells and so
on which is not to say that all
non-white men are celibate there are of
course the occasional chad's of color
with their superior skulls and towering
stature whom the N cells have christened
Tyrone's Chang's and Chad priests I'm so
sorry so you can be in it cell because
of your looks your height your mind or
your race but we unites them all as the
conviction that love and sex are forever
out of reach
unless of course you delusional II
imagine that you can ascend that is
escape your n cell donor if you falsely
and pathetically believe that there is
any possibility of improvement well that
makes you the lowest of the low a sad
and sorry hopes cell second base the red
pill so we have the building blocks of
the in cell world view the stacy is the
Chad's the in cells and the normies from
these elements in cells I've constructed
a theory of human nature and sexuality
which they call the red pill in cells
share the red pill worldview with the
rest of the manosphere that is pickup
artists men's rights activists and the
voluntary celibate community you known
as men going their own way of revealed
in make toe according to red pill theory
women are by nature high Pergamus
hypergamy new greek for marrying above
refers to the practice of seeking
relationships with men above one's
social status and also an in sell you
such
above one's attractiveness according to
n sells physical attractiveness is
naturally distributed equally between
the sexes so if you were to assign
numerical ratings to attractiveness as
in cells like to do there would be about
as many say eight out of ten women has a
den of ten men in cells believe that an
adjust world a five out of ten man would
naturally wind up in a relationship
with his looks match that is
five out of ten woman equivalently
attractive to himself but sadly this
just system has been ruined by hate
Pergamus women who regardless of their
own attractiveness were only interested
in dating Chad in South sometimes call
this the 80/20 rule the idea that only
the top 20% of men will ever be desired
by women now since most heterosexual men
do end up in relationships with women
you might be raising your eyebrow at
that idea but in sales have an
explanation according to the red pill
theory
women often pursue a mating strategy
called alpha [ __ ] beta box this means
that her in her 20s
a woman will as insel say ride the [ __ ]
carousel sleeping with as many Chad's as
possible when she ages into her 30s she
will settle down with a baton or me whom
she's not really attracted to become she
will use for financial support all the
while continuously cuckolding him on the
alpha [ __ ] carousel before inevitably
abandoning him taking him for everything
he's worth on a divorce settlement and
running off to the Mediterranean with
all the children and a new Chad
boyfriend
well the beta [ __ ] has left behind to
fester and alimony payments solitude and
poverty so the upshot of the red pill
theory is that for men there are three
possible outcomes either you're an Enzo
doomed to a lifetime of excruciating
loneliness and resentment or urine or me
destined to wind up in a sexless
marriage with an unfaithful wife who
will divorce you win custody of the
children and run off with all your money
or you could be an alpha an independent
promiscuous man who sleeps with lots of
women and forms attachments to none of
them in the red pill philosophy there
are two ways to become alpha the first
is simply to be a Chad by nature the
second is to become a pickup artist red
Pelt pickup artists believe basically
the same things about women that Anna
sells believe that they are high
Pergamus duplicitous and [ __ ] but
not lovable the difference is that
pickup artists are not celibate in fact
they try to have sex with as many women
as possible by following a series of
strategies and scripts known as game as
described for the book of that title as
well as by the red pill pickup artists
Roosh V author of a book called bang
a new mascara from benefit so the tube
is bomb I am living to see what the wand
looks like oh it's so big whatever it
Roush is up to lately I baked my own
bread yes I am outing myself as a baker
as someone who likes to cook I'm not a
woman
I am ultra masculine as you can see but
baking and cooking in general is a
scientific thing and men like scientific
things I used to be a a scientist well
ruch you know what if it means you leave
women alone I hope you enjoy your new
life as an ultra masculine Baker sorry I
mean bread scientists so remember the
red pill is the realization that women
are high Pergamus by nature 20% or less
of men are really attractive to women
dating as a sexual marketplace and
feminism is a pretext for enabling women
to behave however they want while
consigning men to emasculation and
impotence the black pill is the
additional realization that one's place
in the sexual marketplace is genetically
determined that one is a permanent
version that sex and relationships are
forever out of reach and hence that
happiness is impossible there's nothing
one can do except slide down and rocked
the black pill is essentially dogmatic
hopelessness about dating and about life
in general it's the pinnacle of what
psychotherapists call catastrophizing a
cognitive distortion where anxiety or
depression leads you to infer
apocalyptic conclusions from mundane
setbacks and anxieties for instance a
catastrophizing person might begin with
the thought oh no I'm gonna be late for
work and from there and fer my boss is
gonna be angry I'm gonna lose my job I'm
not gonna be able to get another job I'm
gonna be unemployed forever my family
will starve oh god we're all gonna die
each step in the sequences sort of
plausible for the leap from step one to
step seven is completely absurd this is
exactly how the block pill works
you start with experiences of rejection
and isolation from there you infer that
you are on a tractor to women that you
will never be attractive to any woman
that you will be forever alone that you
will always be unhappy that women did
this to you that feminism empowered
women to do this to you at the social
trends that made this possible are only
getting worse the humanity itself is
doomed and your only option is to lie
down and rot of course not all insults
take things quite so far but a lot of
them do on in soft forums suicidal
is very common and posts are often
tagged to sue a fuel or rope fuel
meaning that they make you want to kill
yourself usually because the reminders
of how hopeless the insel situation is
or how devastating it is that in sales
are missing out on the incredible bliss
of sex and romance now if you suggests
to in cells that posting suah fuel on
forums already populated by lonely and
depressed people is maybe not the most
responsible idea they respond that oh
it's just dark humor it's just a cope
throw as a bone here but a lot of the
suicidal stuff shows no signs of humor
and it's common to see people express
pretty extreme states of depression
which is not surprising since
hopelessness is the logical conclusion
of the plot in the world you know once a
possibility for happiness is determined
by the genetics of height frame and a
facial bone structure and if you don't
have these gifts there's no relief but
to cope a rope now it's pretty tempting
to just mom the [ __ ] out of these kids
you want to grab them by their black ops
t-shirts shake them with it and tell
them there are millions of men with
small wrists and weak Chin's getting
lead every day but that their own worst
enemy is but they need to get off the
computer go outside make some friends
stop hating women get some hobbies and
who knows maybe they'll develop a
disposition that women find a little
more approachable essentially you want
to tell them
clean your room bucco and fart for the
young men in this demographic who are
receptive to that kind of advice Jordan
Peterson is probably helpful because
he's telling them a lot of what they
need to hear and he's kind of a sexist
old man so they might actually listen
but most in cells don't want to hear
this kind of advice in fact they view it
as essentially a microaggression you are
in effect Chadds planing their
oppression to them when you give basic
advice like take a shower be more
confident to people who have already
experienced a lifetime of rejection in
isolation and who believe if they've
already tried everything
so they despise this kind of advice and
devote endless posts to bitterly mocking
the futility and insensitivity of it
just go out to parties brah instead of
hating on women all day why don't you
losers just try being confident like
this everything good guy confidence is
key you in cells need some hobbies try
reading some books
women love intelligence it works for me
bro oh you just need to get out
no one knows what it's like to be hated
to in sells their world view seems
ironclad it has built-in defenses
against anyone who would try to change
their minds so if you want to understand
in cells and in particular if you want
to understand why their community
produces so many mass murderers you have
to understand that the black pill is
more than the dogma that you can't get
laid it's also the dogma that because
you can't get laid you can never be
happy so we have in our hands here is
more than a bunch of angry internet
misogynists it's at worst a kind of
death cult complete with an eternal hell
than an omnipotent enemy it is not
surprising that that state of mind leads
a few of them to conclude that since
triumph is impossible why not try
revenge third base tinder is garbage I
know I said I wasn't gonna sympathize
with in cells and I know they don't want
my sympathy anyway and I know it's bad
practices to sympathize with the devil
but on some level I can't help it the
internet is for introverts so I'm sure a
lot of people watching this feel the
same way I bet some of you have been
this guy I have been this guy so look
I'm gonna tell you something I've never
really come out about on this channel so
this is like a really vulnerable moment
for me but I used to live as a man and
I'm not proud of that but I'm ready to
move on if you're ready to forgive I'm
in the unusual situation of being a
woman who date's men who used to be a
man who date's women what kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] is that is that even allowed
alright cop down lesbians stands I'm
still attracted to women and those who
lieth betwixt cats the inherent
eroticism of the sea yeah don't you just
want to get in there
take me money but I have it on a
heterosexual kick lately I got to get my
edirol on what I'm getting at is I've
used tinder both's is a man seeking
women and as a woman seeking men and I
think that gives me some relevant
experiences when you're a man
the strategy is you've got to send a lot
of messages because women get a lot of
messages and then you just got to try to
be less of an ogre than the other
fuckboys whereas if you're a woman you
get to lie recumbent on your shades long
and receive the enquiries let's see how
we're doing here how many men have liked
me on tinder I'm paying $30 for this
information so that's better be good
I have 2,500 likes that's a lot of
Baltimore Ian man who's swiped right on
a Tran what a defined City that's some
rates of them to be interested in me
let's see what kind of message is I got
dick or no deck pre-op or post-op did
you cut your dick off oh my god I'm
gonna cut it off okay Jesus
I will let you smash my pussy's so so
hard if you just be patient it's it's a
whole process that's not a [ __ ] that's
a [ __ ] hole you'll never know what it's
like to squeeze life out of your sacred
passage well that's true I am NOT gonna
be squeezing any life out unless
something goes a very seriously wrong
and I assure you that none of the
passages I have down there have ever
been or ever will be sacred
ah be yellow leave my [ __ ] hole out of
this when I first started using this app
I was messaging with a guy who seemed
super chill he's gonna take me to a
concert I was like seems like a lot for
a birthday but we'll try it 15 minutes
after we agreed to that he sends me a
message what color panties are you
wearing
I would love to smell them can we get
coffee first the hell of it is I
probably would have let him smell my
panties but this is the thing you bring
up on the third [ __ ] you don't open with
panty sniffing like the only point of in
a messaging is for me to figure out if
you're gonna murder me and you're
already [ __ ] it up so those are the
experience of women
we're drowning a dick and most of it is
terrible not all I do have some very
sweet messages and I haven't been using
the app in a couple months so if I
didn't respond to you or if we didn't
match it's not because I rejected you
it's because I don't like the app people
screenshot my profile and they post it
online and they call me khakhra points
and out like I was too famous for this
[ __ ] my life is hard so girls we do a
lot of complaining about the firing
squad of bad dicks that's constantly
pointed at us in dating apps but how
would you feel if instead of it you were
just getting radio silence like the N
cells get I can't speak for other women
but personally I prefer the firing squad
of dicks you know at least these pricks
care enough about my [ __ ] to be an
[ __ ] about my deck I feel sorry for
men on dating apps I really do you have
to deal with a lot of rejection and
there must be difficult these apps are
especially brutal to people who aren't
photogenic if you're meeting people at a
bar or a party you might strike up a
conversation with someone who you're not
initially physically attracted to but
then maybe they're super funny or
charming or maybe they're attracted to
me and that's an attractive quality and
another person that they appreciate how
beautiful I am but on tinder you're just
browsing a catalogue of faces and
gatekeeping who even gets to talk to you
in the first place red pillars have a
really gross way of talking about dating
in terms of sexual market value but like
dating kind of is a marketplace or at
least you can analyze it like one and
her culture is so visual these apps are
so picture centered that bone structure
like it's not the only thing that
matters but it matters a great deal and
this is where I do have sympathy for the
in cells because as a trans woman I know
what it's like to obsess over
millimeters of bone I actually have to
interrupt work on this video to go to a
consultation for facial feminization
surgery so I can pay luxury car amounts
of money to shave off a few millimeters
of bone hair there because it must needs
be remarked that the skull of the female
exhibit anthem drawbridge less
pronounced I mean I'm just as obsessed
with bone structure as the goddamn mint
cells because I think certain parts in
my face make me look like a man
and I worry about it every day we're all
obsessed with the bones honey we all
have bones inside us we all love
touching bones you want to take a
measurement from the barbell range the
lambdoid suture and multiply that figure
by pi to calculate when we go the Chad
circumference why is no one talking
about the Chad circumference fourth base
just the tip there's another way I think
my experience as a transwoman
is relevant to the in cell discussion
and that's that I recognize delusional
self-loathing when I see it I'm far from
the first to point out that the supreme
gentleman in cell mass murderer elliot
rodger was a partner his narcissistic
psychopath personality an eminently
bangable twink and i'm not going to show
you pictures of in cells but on their
forums they do sometimes post selfie
threads and you can't say this on itself
forms without enraging them but in
confidence from one pretend clinician to
another let me tell you that the truth
about themselves is that almost all of
them are completely normal looking guys
but of course that's not the feedback
they got it from other in cells the
feedback they get is that their chins
are weak their hair is thin their skin
is garbage and there's no hope
whatsoever no woman will ever love them
and there are true cells with no option
but to lie down in Ron and the
interesting thing is those guys post
selfies to those threads knowing that's
the kind of feedback they're gonna get
so why why do they do it well I'll tell
you a little story there is a website on
the internet called 4chan org that has a
board called LGBT a few years ago this
was used mainly by the 25 gay men who
actually like Milo innopolis but
recently it's used mostly by men who are
entertaining the notion
becoming women and by early transition
trans women so the board is jokingly
called tttt now I've recently moved
beyond that first stage of my transition
but the memory is still fresh and let me
tell you it is a painful awkward
humiliating stage of life so the
transfer of tttt are tragic
they're basically still in man mode
which is why they're using for sham and
I bring them up because they remind me a
lot of in cells
for in cells the core frustration is
that they can't get laid for tttt if
nothing can't pass as female both groups
post selfies knowing they're gonna get
brutal unconstructive feedback and both
groups have a weird vocabulary with
which to express their anxieties for
instance on tttt a major piece of jargon
is hun a slur used by trans women for
other trans women which basically means
that you look like a man in a dress
which is what every trans woman is
afraid of and there's another
commonality within cells too with all
bigots and self Luthor's which if you've
been paying attention you've already
guessed you will never be seen as a
woman because of your head size have all
the surgeries in the world a massive man
Nagin will stay the same
well this freak thinks he has very soft
facial features his head is [ __ ] huge
and the huns on reddit are hug boxing
him and telling him that there are women
with big heads you transition with the
man's head you will be clock you will be
looked at as a freak you will never be
seen as a legit one this is why I'm not
transitioning Thank You
skull people for showing me the way and
that no matter what I do I will always
be a manly man
Scholl Weiss you saved me the
embarrassment of
being a little big-headed manager tears
evidence the cranial vault of the auto
guider file be much more voluminous into
the facial plain wider it always comes
back to the skulls every time the other
interesting thing about tttt is eyes to
get posted there a lot for a while I had
some stands on the ward who basically
viewed me as inspiration
yikes because of course that kind of
post is frowned upon if I'm not looked
at as a big scold me on freak if my
transition is going well that means that
some of their transitions might be able
to and that is an unacceptable
conclusion for a community founded on
self-loathing and hopelessness so it was
necessary for the rest of the board to
explain what I didn't pass why I would
never pass why anyone who looked less
good than me shouldn't even [ __ ]
think about it we shouldn't transition
at all they should just repress they
should lie down in rock and I used to
read the stuff all the time
like I was specifically seek on threads
about me which might seem strange
considering I had hundreds of fans
telling you is a gorgeous goddess every
day so why did I turn away from that to
intentionally seek out this dismal den
of Huns talking about how my giant Han
skull is claw Keable at a thousand paces
and my voice sounds like a ridiculous
Muppet falsetto hybrid of Mickey Mouse
and Winnie the Pooh well basically there
was part of my brain that just simply
refused to believe it when people told
me I was gorgeous and first semi
plausible reasons a lot of trans people
in the internet tell other trans people
they look gorgeous no matter what they
look like that's where the word Han
comes from you let gray hun so a tttt is
saying about reddit hog boxing is true
to some extent there is a kind of a
priori and dogmatic flattery that
prevails in some trans spaces so I came
to regard all compliments as everyone is
beautiful politically correct cuckoldry
and there would be this thrill of going
to tttt and reading other people saying
when my deepest anxieties told me was
really true and that was always painful
but there was a kind of pleasure - there
was a rush
it's exciting to burst out of the
politically correct bubble and say what
you're really thinking that personality
doesn't matter because big scold chad's
get all the girls the Contra points is a
big scold hunt with a voice like nails
on a chalkboard and at first I justified
the habit by telling myself I was just
doing research I have to keep tabs and
what the bigots are saying it's simply
my job but soon I realized it wasn't
just research and it was infecting me
away from the computer this ridiculous
vocabulary puns AGP was popping up in my
head unexpected times it was starting to
color how I thought about myself and
worse it was starting to infect how I
thought about other trans women and
that's the moment I realized I need to
stop looking at this stuff right now or
I'm gonna become a monster and once that
happens it's gonna be very difficult to
fix this is exactly how the in sell
black pill works there's something
infectious about these vocabularies like
on days I've been working on this video
I'll go out at night and these words
just didn't volunteer ilish oh up in my
thoughts that bartender is such a Chad
he's totally height walking that tiny
[ __ ] and the tragic thing is some in
sales don't realize it what this is
doing to their minds until it's too late
let's face it
black pills are silly fuel a lot of us
can't handle them i gleefully indulged
in this sub red at the moment I
discovered it since I loved uncovering
secrets that society had been hiding
from me but it has affected my mental
health in a bad way I made my first call
to the suicide hotline a few weeks ago
and I've never needed to do that before
I could always talk myself out of it
through logic but my mind is ruined now
this is a form of what psychologists are
calling digital self-harm prototypically
teens who leave themselves abusive
comments from sock puppet accounts but
the more sophisticated adult version of
this involves intentionally seeking out
abusive and disparaging comments about
yourself made by other people I have a
long history of doing this intentionally
looking for a piece of comments
especially once that cut to the core of
my deepest insecurities and fears why I
why do people cut themselves part of it
is what we could call masochistic
epistemology whatever hurts is true I've
recently gotten much better about this I
haven't been to any of the worst places
in a couple months and my mental health
is much improved so insults I'm not
going to respond to your worldview like
it's an intellectual position or the of
rational debate because these ideas and
arguments you're not using them the way
rational people use arguments you're
using them as razor blades to abuse
yourselves and I know because I've done
the exact same thing the insult
worldview is catastrophizing it's an
anxious death spiral and the solution to
that has to be therapeutic not logical a
lot of you are lonely you've been
bullied and neglected you feel left
behind by society but what you're doing
when you're reading in cell forums is
you're slowly internalizing a cruel and
distorted way of looking at yourselves
and to other people in your situation
and at women and you're forming mental
habits that are gonna make it very
difficult for you to live a happy life
so what you have to do is get off those
forums as fast as possible I'm going to
post a link in the description of this
video to instructions on how to block
certain websites from your computer
because for me that's what it took fifth
base anal so the innocent reddit
transgender 4chan analogy has a limit
and that limit is that for a significant
subset of the insel community their
primary hatred is not directed at
themselves but at women and they really
hate
like I'm basically a professional
Internet bigotry scholar at this point I
look at this kind of stuff all the time
but researching this video I was
honestly kind of shocked at the
intensity of misogyny on himself forums
I won't show the worst of it but we're
talking women for rape saying they
deserve to be raped calls for
state-mandated girlfriends and sex
slaves but most of all just kind of
generalized misinformed rage I hate
women I really do every time I look at
my blood pressure shoots through the
roof when they're gabbing on the cell
phone about Paris Hilton when they're
adjusting their lipstick and taking up
my time rifling through their stupid
purse when they whined to me about their
period when they believe they're on and
on about some artists film director
musician nobody gives a flippin [ __ ]
about when they cry and expect your
personal sympathy but most of all I hate
them because their smug hyperactive
little [ __ ] made that way by our
[ __ ] society
look what uncontrolled feminism and the
media has died Stacy it's Tracy what was
it the mall the other day with Amber
Heather Jenna and Trish and we were
talking about Paris Hilton a very
relevant cultural figure in 2018 they
live in this cartoon caricature world
where it's easy to avoid thinking of
women is fully human and that's where my
sympathy runs dry because this kind of
hatred just needs a spark to turn to
violence
soin Souls I know you're not gonna
listen to anything I say and you're just
gonna say that I'm a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
and a degenerate and to that I say how
dare you say things that are entirely
true but also of also if you would have
[ __ ] and I know you don't listen to
suggestions about how you probably
actually could have healthy
relationships so no one can really reach
you until you get out of those forums
and allow yourselves to be reached but
by way of a closing remark I guess I
simply invite you to consider that you
don't even need a warm body or a sex
robot to satisfied the erotic longing
you know when I was your age in 1975
every teenage boy had a Stratocaster in
his bedroom
that was the outlet for his sexual
frustration what I'm suggesting is the
manosphere exists because rock-and-roll
is dead but there's other options
think about the eroticism of a rain
storm the clap of thunder the rustle of
the leaves the steam rising off the warm
pavement and whether you're a Chad a
Stacey and n cell or a hun you could
always return to the caress of our dark
mother the see who's salty embrace and
develops every contour of your naked
body
[Music]
whoa is it hot in here or is it just me